detrimental step it's a lot of these
guys are pretty intelligent but
sometimes intelligent people are just
the dumbest people on Earth for all of
human history really rich selfish people
have tried to figure out how to live
forever and we're living in such a
stupid time that we're this has been
going on for all of history and people
now go online and they say wow you know
we're really close to living forever
this time we've almost figured it out
spoiler alert they're not going to
figure it out that's not a real thing
you're just gonna kill a bunch of people
in the process yes trying to find out
you're going to kill a bunch of people
you're going to cause all sorts of havoc
and it's that same Lie from the Garden
of Eden which is the lie that ye shall
be as Gods Ferrari refers to this as
homo Deus that we're now going to take
control over the future of humanity and
you think okay good luck buddy I mean
unfortunately it's going to cause lots
of problems in the short term but it
ain't gonna work man